this morning the long-running and costly
war in Afghanistan for US forces took a
major turn the u.s. and the Taliban
signed an historic peace deal in Qatar
the agreement is aimed at ending years
of US blood and treasure being spilled
in Afghanistan and allowing American
forces to return home MTS ty ab is in
London with the latest MTS good morning
good morning well history was made today
with the signing of a deal that could
see an end to America's longest war
defense secretary Mike Esper was in
Kabul alongside political leaders to
witness the agreement and Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo was in the country
capital Doha at another ceremony with
the former rulers of Afghanistan who
when last in power brutalized their own
people and sheltered Osama bin Laden and
al Qaeda as they plotted the September
11th attacks but after nearly 19 years
of bitter fighting and over a year of
tense negotiations we now have a deal
that will reduce the current number of
US troops in Afghanistan around 13,000
to 8600 within 135 days there's also the
potential of a full US withdrawal from
Afghanistan within 14 months all of
which depends on the Taliban keeping up
its end of the bargain a bargain that
includes severing ties with al Qaeda and
opening up negotiations with other
Afghan factions including the us-backed
government for a potential power sharing
agreement all with the hopes it will
lead to a lasting ceasefire not part of
the deal any commitments from the
Taliban to protect the civil rights of
people they so brutally repressed when
last empower particularly women who at
least in major urban centers have made
very important strides still after
nearly two decades of grinding warfare
which has cost over a trillion dollars
and has claimed the lives of over 3,500
US and coalition troops as well as many
tens of thousands of Afghans few want to
see the fighting continued and hope this
really is the beginning of the end okay
yes thank you very much